now the Ukrainian MP lessia vaselenko
has been on the program before but
always from her home country today I'm
very pleased to say that she joins us
live here it's lovely to see you in
person and thank you so much for coming
in a real pleasure to have you uh here
um can you just update us on what's the
latest on the ground in Ukraine it's
been a very difficult weekend and
yesterday the whole country and everyone
whose Ukrainian has been absolutely
devastated at the missiles in fact I was
on a call was was a friend early in the
morning yesterday and all of a sudden he
says to me there's explosions but there
has not been any air raid sirens and it
has been that the case for most of
Ukraine yesterday there's not been Air
Raid Sirens to warn the people of these
missiles that Russia launched because as
our ministry of Defense reported later
it's the kind of missiles that cannot
really be detected especially from the
direction that Russia was launching
yesterday and there's as a result of
world has seen the destroyed residential
blocks in abroad the massive holes from
the missiles in in some Ukrainian
Villages just a couple of kilometers out
from Kiev and it's just been yet another
human tragedy added to the long list of
human tragedies caused by Russia you
know I'll say an intro introduction to
you you know there's been more strikes
on civilian targets civilian targets I
mean like you say that means holes in
apartment blocks right absolutely that
means that means innocent men women
children who were not expecting this on
a Saturday especially after a certain
kind of festive period which was
prolonged in Ukraine
and
it's just not something that you expect
it's just not something that and even in
the middle of the war and you know that
your country is in the war every single
moment of the day but still you're sort
of hoping that it will stick to the
Battleground you are hoping that maybe
okay military targets will be targeted
but not your home not the home of your
loved ones of your friends you don't
expect to spend your Saturday on the
phone constantly calling family from
asking whether whether they're alive or
not
and now Ukraine is poised to see
more Russian forces
are you worried about the direction of
the war well we are worried first of all
that there will be more missile strikes
in the coming days because we know from
intelligence that Russia has not
exhausted even half of their Arsenal
that was intended for these attacks and
we know that there is uh missile
launcher
cargo ships in the in the marine regions
ready to go so this is this is something
we are preparing the short term and the
long term of course and the midterm uh
it is expected that Russia will regroup
and will start relaunching the attacks
especially with spring when the calls
will be not so when it will not be so
difficult because of the call to to make
advancements and this is why Ukraine is
constantly on the ask for more weapons
and for these tanks as you just
mentioned that the UK will be sending
tanks Challenger tanks to Ukraine we are
extremely grateful for that and we are
hoping that Germany will see this as an
example to follow and will eventually
give way and give us the the tanks and
the armored vehicles we have been so
desperately asking for to have that uh
that benefit on the Battleground let's
talk about the tanks and because as you
say the UK is sending Challenger 2 tanks
the first time a western country has
pledged tanks how important is that uh
the fighting on the on the ground on the
eastern Southeastern Northeastern
Borders or contact line for Ukraine it's
crucial that we have artillery on the
ground it's crucial that we have tanks
on the ground because this is what
Russia is fighting us with so we need
this as defense vehicles but we also
need these as counter-offensive
instruments to push the Russians back
and it is crucial that we do this by the
end of spring that would get a pushback
of Russian forces beyond the Ukraine
Russian borders the 1991 Ukraine Russian
borders and that we secure the area with
with proper defense structures and
facilities and to do that we need these
uh these heavy weapons which are the
tanks you you said that you hope Germany
follows the UK's example do you think
that some countries
are not doing enough
uh while Germany being one of them I
mean they have these weapons sitting
there that they are not using and that
hopefully fingers crossed they will not
have to use because Ukraine will be
Victorious and will manage to fight off
the biggest aggressor in Europe so for
Germany not to have to use these tanks
they need to be in Ukraine on the ground
fighting and the same goes for every
single country who still has weapons and
the storage units and the storage houses
and is stalling from giving them to
Ukraine because the only threat in
Europe at this moment and one of the
largest threats to Security in the world
is Russia and the only country that can
physically stop Russia is Ukraine and we
are happy to do this on the ground
within our territory we are happy to
push back Russia within its borders but
we need the means to do it and this is
this is why the appeals from our
Minister of Defense from a foreign
minister from our president from every
single Ukrainian gave us weapons give us
the tanks give us the anti-air
weapons and systems that we need give us
the ammunition to go with are you it's
interesting isn't it because um you know
speaking to you today making these calls
is it often that women of Ukraine who
are having to come on programs like this
who are having to speak to the
politicians to travel the world because
the men are fighting it's definitely
easier for the women to cross the
borders even if we're talking about
women who are in politics who are in
people who are in politics or in
government positions it still is easier
because uh the women are not
um well not eligible for a mandatory
military service so we are free to cross
the border when when we we like when it
comes to the men if you are from 18 to
60 uh the rule of thumb is that you are
eligible for military service and you
cannot leave the country as you please
you need to get authorizations you need
to prove that you will be coming back
that and that the mission you're going
to abroad is really really necessary
sorry so of course it's it's easier for
the women to make these appeals but
regardless who's making these appeals
even if it's not ukrainians who are
making these appeals I really wish that
these appeals would be answered because
today the best humanitarian Aid that can
be sent to Ukraine is weapons to fight
off the Russians
um I was really struck by photograph
that you posted on Twitter just before
Christmas
um I think we can hopefully uh have a
look at it it's of you and your family
can you just explain what's happening in
this picture
well uh this is my youngest uh she's a
toddler 18 month old and we are in a
makeshift bomb shelter from a basement
in uh in an apartment block just next
door two hours and the thing is I was uh
going out to the park with Sophia uh
because to give her her nap but she she
only naps outside and all of a sudden uh
the there were explosions which started
just the stuff started blowing up
somewhere very close to us because these
explosions were very much intense and
there was the smell of smoke of sulfur
immediately in the air and as we started
making our way back home we were ushered
in by uh just people from the next
apartment block saying come in come and
you need to go into the basement right
now and this is exactly what happened so
her nap was was interrupted
um of course she's not sleeping there
and there you have my friend in the
picture who said trying to entertain her
with some Peppa Pig
kind of blows my mind you know you talk
about something that is so familiar and
ordinary to so many people watching you
totally won't sleep so you take them in
the prams to try and take them outside
you know you want them to be quiet so
you put Peppa Pig on the phone
and yet it's in such an extraordinary
situation for a parent I I can't imagine
you know I talked to you as a politician
but also as a mother
um I just can't really grasp
what people in Ukraine are having to go
through uh you know neither can I
because it's just
um it just doesn't sit well with the
ordinary with the normal life of a
person living in the modern world
uh you cannot piece the puzzle together
and I think that after the victory after
Ukraine wins we will have a lot of
mending to do and a lot of healing to do
because all of these things which our
brain doesn't allow us really to
register and to grasp and what we are
actually doing uh they are going to
flood us and there's going to be a lot
of issues to deal with both for the
people who will be coming back from the
front lines as well as the people who
will be coming back from abroad as well
as the people who have had to stay and
live through these Air Raids because it
does feel like the whole of Ukraine it's
a front line the whole of Ukraine is a
Frontline and it's a fact and do you
think that you can win them absolutely
we have no other choice you have no
other choice we have to win this war for
uh democracy sake uh this is an
existential War for Ukraine it's
existential because we want to exist we
want to live so this is why we are
fighting but for uh people who are
supporting us for the UK for example
it's an existential War because it's
existential between good and evil who do
you want to and you won't get to win you
want the world to be a safe place you
don't want to be seeing pictures like
this on Sunday morning and you most
certainly don't want to be living
through pictures like this any day of
your life and in order for this not to
happen you need to make sure that Russia
loses Russia losing must become a very
clear statement in everyone's mind a
very clear idea and one that everyone
can back and support and thank you so
much for being on the program it's been
a real privilege to meet you thank you
thank you Sophie